[Music]
hello everyone my name is Laura bandura
and I'm a research geophysicist at
Chevron some of you may remember that I
was on stage at Google next last July
back then I talked about how to make
sense out of way too much data we were
using Google clouds Auto ml vision API
to analyze the content of thousands of
Geoscience documents and to make them
searchable my goal then was to describe
how we could quickly access and utilize
the work documented by thousands of
Chevron employees in the form of field
reports seismic recordings core samples
lab analyses environmental studies and
much more with Google Cloud we got it in
one place digitized it and through the
power of machine learning gave this data
a new life today I want to tell you how
far we've come with that project and how
we've added tools to do something far
more valuable creating a new way of
consuming information by a diet by a
rich and diverse team of people and
acting faster to achieve our business
goals the energy business literally
powers the modern world for someone like
me part of the excitement is
understanding how we use geology and
geophysics to understand the subsurface
of the earth in my work we use seismic
waves to probe the subsurface geology
those measurements are then used to
create detailed pictures of what the
earth looks like deep into the past and
also to help us determine where oil and
gas are located here we shown an example
of a modern river system containing
channel features that have similar
dimensions and patterns to features that
we tried to find in the subsurface for
exploration and in one of these examples
is this image of a submarine canyon
system that we've found within seismic
data but the excitement doesn't stop
there the next step is to connect our
interpretations of these images to the
value chain and to ultimately impact how
we produce oil and gas
for an integrated energy company like
Chevron that mean that means working
with multiple teams globally that
include research scientists engineers
and analysts some of us are working in
offices interpreting data and others are
out in the field conducting operations
communicating with our peers across
Geographic and language boundaries and
across subject matter domains is nothing
new to Chevron in fact we've done this
very well for over a century over time
however information can become siloed
what if we could create some common
digital spaces where all teams could
look at all of the available information
to support the work that they are doing
what if all of Chevron's experts could
have the best data available at all
times regardless of where they are
located or what their technical
specialty is how would we organize
something like that and the answer is to
take take things back to basics and for
us that is the earth and to build it up
in a whole new way on Google cloud we've
created a system that digitizes text
tables and images all sorts of notations
and data readings we've made everything
searchable through metadata that was
automatically generated with auto ml we
utilize custom geologic labels to take
images and use knowledge graphs to
summarize field reports with natural
language processing and translation we
created it created an enormous index of
our data and documents that is now
searchable in any language this means
that data from years ago can be combined
with more recent findings or matched
against technology improvements that
we've made and field development
planning in safety or even in well
completions giving new life to work that
took place many years ago where physical
and geographical data are concerned
Google Earth is the key technology for
visualization we can take the surface
view of the earth and then expand it to
create a view of its below surface
features as well as we know them from
decades of our work and I
explosion and production populating it
with information like seismic data and
well logs that describe transitions
between geologic layers we can add
publicly available information about
surrounding geologies and industry
activities developing still richer ways
of seeing our data with new
understanding and this is really
literally decades of human work seen in
the context of millions of years of
geology and this is really just the
beginning for us we have new ways of
seeing and using legacy and modern data
and linking it with real time business
processes happening within Chevron
around the globe each day from earth
science to facilities engineering to
environment and safety and beyond
through our collaboration with Google we
have developed a framework that enables
us to do more together connecting our
technical experts to our data and to
each other and that's really made
possible by what our hosts today are
calling one Google thank you
[Music]